[Musique]
nous voici devant le portail de la
crosse avec Didier fontaine professeur
des écoles en CE2 bonjour Didier bonjour
Benoît que représente
ce portail de la crosse c'est une
symbolique importante pour l'institution
marmotier symbolique important puisque
c'est le grand monument enfin le grand
bâtiment vu par tous les gens qui
passent devant Marmoutier voilà c'est
notre façade belle façade qualifiée par
Prosper Mérimée en son temps comme plus
belle entrée d'abbaye d'Occident et elle
a vu également on voit Saint-Martin qui
partage son manteau alors la symbolique
du manteau partagé par Saint-Martin bien
sûr quand Saint-Martin qui a été humaine
à l'âge de 18 ans partagea son manteau
avec un pauvre à l'entrée donc de la
ville d'Amiens voilà donc en 334
vous avez eu l'occasion de voir donc
cette entrée d'abbaye qui est qui a
quand même l'apparence d'une petite
bastide d'un petit bastion avec une
architecture plutôt militaire donc avec
aspect crénelé avec meurtrière tour de
défense etc qui n'avait pas de vocation
défensive mais simplement une notion de
décorum un aspect de décorum pour
montrer la puissance des habits du lieu
et la stature
on va maintenant aller ensemble visiter
cette majestueuse abbaye de Marmoutier
venez avec nous
c'est quoi deux de dispenser des cours
dans ce théâtre historique c'est ça
alors nous avons la chance d'être dans
un théâtre historique effectivement
important pour tout pour la ville de
Tours pour la martinopolis en son temps
parce que nous savons que la ville de
Tours a grandi au Moyen-Âge grâce au
pèlerinage donc sur les sur les reliques
de Saint-Martin
nous avons gardé également alors ces
cuvettes qui correspondent au cuvettes
original qui était celle des différents
jardins
on se retrouve au pied du site Martinien
ou tout a commencé ça le site originel
donc à partir de 371 quand Martin est à
la fois évêque de la ville de Tours et
également le supérieur d'une communauté
de moines qui comptera bientôt 80
membres voilà dans ce qu'on appelle une
Laure alors une or c'est une communauté
d'un accordètes voilà donc alors
c'est-à-dire des gens qui vivaient seuls
dans la journée et qui se retrouvait au
moment des repas et au moment évidemment
des messes des prières en commun Martin
voulait être à la voix dans une vie
publique puisqu'il était évêque de Tours
et il était très très accueillant pour
chacun pour chaque paroissien mais il
émet aussi avoir des temps de
recueillement pour la prière et donc
pour lui Marmoutier était son désert
merci beaucoup Didier de nous avoir
présenté ce lieu majestueux vous restez
avec nous on va maintenant retrouver
Florence bolet c'est la directrice de
l'école élémentaire et elle va nous
présenter
quelques petites trésors dont un
oratoire juste au-dessus du portail de
la crosse où nous étions tout à l'heure
où sommes-nous précisément et bien ici
nous sommes dans l'oratoire de Madeleine
Sophie Barat qui est donc la fondatrice
de notre institution
18008 Madeleine Sophie a créé son
deuxième établissement scolaire après
Amiens qui était le berceau et elle est
elle avait choisi cet endroit pour sa
beauté elle était extrêmement sensible à
la beauté des lieux alors aujourd'hui
il y a combien de d'élèves au sein de
l'institution alors nous avons environ
1000 élèves on accueille les enfants
depuis la petite section jusqu'au BTS
donc sur un bel espace de 7 hectares et
demi s'il fait que chaque unité
pédagogique bénéficie d'un espace
important on est une école de ville à la
campagne en fait
et bien sûr vous souhaitez inculquer la
bienveillance l'accompagnement tout est
fait pour permettre aux enfants de
s'épanouir dans un lieu remarquable
exactement et c'est en ça que nous
continuons à en faire vivre le charisme
de Madeleine Sophie qui avait déjà il y
a 200 ans bientôt cette modernité dans
son approche de l'éducation merci
beaucoup Florence boulet bon courage
pour cette nouvelle année combien
d'élèves précisément cette année
990 environ un lieu remarquable que nous
avons fait découvrir si vous avez des
enfants à scolariser n'hésitez pas venez
à Marmoutier ou bien venez juste pour
visiter ce site historique majeur en
toile
[Musique]